Speaker 1: Many people going bonkers about
the reportedly accepted offer for Elon Musk
to buy Twitter.
There are people who on the right are welcoming
this with open arms, saying free speech will
return to Twitter and oh, it's going to be
great.
And you have people on the left saying this
is a dystopian nightmare.
Let's talk through what's going on and then
I will give you my take on it.
Twitter has accepted Elon Musk's buyout deal.
The report is that Twitter's board has accepted
the offer for Elon Musk to take the company
private.
Twitter's a publicly traded company right
now.
The idea would be that Elon Musk has secured
financing at 5420 per share to buy the company
and to take it private.
There were rumors floating that many said
there's no way this is happening and it appears
to be now.
It still needs to actually go through the
due diligence and regulation phase and it's
possible that this will fall apart.
But I'm more concerned with what the reaction
to this should be now.
One of the problems I'm having with the reaction
for many is that it is very, very black and
white either.
This is our Elon Musk is our savior, and he's
going to save Twitter and he's going to unbanned
everybody.
And Trump will be back and all of these different
things.
And then the other side of it is that this
is the absolute worst thing that could happen
because Elon Musk is just an absolutely terrible
person.
One of the problems that we're facing in the
United States and around the world, but in
the United States, is that everything is based
around personalities and cults of personality.
And I think we should resist that and we should
resist it very strongly.
As I've said before, when it comes to elected
officials, I don't see politicians and elected
officials as being any different than you
or I. They're just people.
They have some good ideas.
They have some bad ideas.
They have good instincts.
They have bad instincts.
And we've talked about the dangerous cult
of personality around Donald Trump.
But I was the first to tell you as a Bernie
supporter in 16 and 20, I didn't like the
cult of personality that developed around
Bernie.
Bernie can do no wrong.
Oh, you don't like what he said?
Well, you must have misunderstood what he
said, or you're deliberately misstating what
he said.
He no, he can do no wrong.
Cult of personality around Tulsi Gabbard.
There was one around Andrew Yang, there's
one around Jordan Peterson.
I'm against all of it.
We need to just see people as more nuanced
than that.
And so when we talk about someone like Elon
Musk, that's who's at question here.
Does Elon Musk have a history of suppressing
unionization at his companies?
Yeah.
Yeah, and I'm against that.
That's not good.
Has Elon Musk dramatically accelerated the
path forward on a number of important technologies?
100%.
The current rush that every manufacturer of
automobiles has not only to put out electric
vehicles, but to put out electric vehicles
whose range can match that of Tesla is only
happening because of what Elon Musk did with
Tesla and at Tesla.
Bad things have also happened.
There's allegations of racism, there's allegations
of union busting, all of these different things.
But the Tesla advancement of electric vehicles
with a greater than 300 mile range as a just
normal thing, has led to Chevy, Ford, Audi,
Mercedes, RIVIAN, all these different companies
saying, hey, we got to up our game, we've
got to compete here.
That's a great thing.
When you talk about the return to space and
space X Musk reinvigorated what is now an
increased interest in getting back to space,
which I think is good.
StarLink satellite internet anywhere in the
world, these are great things.
And from a business standpoint, I've learned
it's not a good bet to bet against Elon Musk
when he's determined to do something.
And he also has some terrible political instincts,
tweets, horrible things, and has all of these
other things that that aren't very progressive
to me.
The track record on Free Speech, as we have
a report from CNBC about Musk's record on
free speech.
It's not a great record.
He has sought control over what journalists,
bloggers, analysts and others say about his
businesses.
He's reportedly canceled people's to a bloggers
Tesla order when the blogger blogged something
Elon Musk didn't like.
So what does this mean for Twitter?
I have absolutely no idea.
It could be bad, there's no doubt about it.
But I think the problem I'm having is that
all of the discussion, 99% of the discussion
is based around people's preexisting opinion
about Elon Musk as a uniquely great figure
or is a uniquely terrible figure.
And that seems.
Ordinarily short sighted.
My main concern with Musk buying Twitter is
that of consolidation and monopoly.
I don't really love the idea of one person
controlling so many major companies.
Elon Musk's going to control Twitter.
And Tesla, which is now, I believe, by market
cap, the largest auto manufacturer in the
United States, and SpaceX, which is, I believe,
the most important private space exploration
company.
It started.
The consolidation of power is my primary concern.
Will Trump be back on Twitter as a result,
like as Elon Musk planning to unbanned Trump?
I have absolutely no idea.
Trump says he doesn't plan to go back on.
That may change.
That seems like a minor detail at this point.
So let me know your thoughts about the Twitter
takeover, but try to make them substantive
rather than driven by just your opinion of
Elon Musk as an individual, which the right
just is there praying at the altar of Musk
and it seems unhinged.
And also, I'm seeing some on the left who
are just painting him as a uniquely evil character,
which also doesn't strike me as accurate.
Let me know your thoughts.
I'm on Twitter.
A deep hackman.
The David Pakman Show is an audience supported
program and I would love for you to sign up
at.
Join Pacman dot com.
Get yourself a membership.
You'll get an extra show every day called
the bonus show.
Alex Jones hates the bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: He hates it.
That's a sign.
It's probably pretty cool.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com and
you can use the coupon code.
Wow.
22 to get a discount.